c'est bon pour vous vous avez pas besoin
qu'on vous emmène non non ça va aller
presque tous les jours depuis une
semaine police municipale et élus sont
présents à la sortie du collège Pierre
de Coubertin de Chevreuse après
plusieurs jours de perturbation sur le
réseau des bus Transdev tout n'est pas
encore revenu à la normale là
aujourd'hui nous manque la ligne 3917
sur le le parking du collège
c'est-à-dire la ligne qui permet de
ramener les enfants à la gare de
Saint-Rémi les Chevreuse c'est une ligne
qui est qui est vraiment structurante
pour le territoire et qui manifestement
a oublié de passer par le col
à 4h donc l'heure à laquelle finissent
les enfants aujourd'hui un bus qui ne
passe pas et ce sont plusieurs élèves
qui sont sur le carreau ce jour-là moi
par exemple j'habite à courcell j'habite
super loin bah faut que je pr je marche
jusqu'à la gare je prenne le herur pour
rentrer chez moi je mets tout le temps
20 ans à rentrer chez moi du coup ça ass
long quoi là on va retourner à pied une
situation qui dure depuis le 1er janvier
date à laquelle les lignes de bus en
Vallée de Chevreuse ont changé
d'opérateur anciennement assuré par la
SAVAC c'est maintenant Transdev Eveline
qui a repris le trafic dans cette zone
un changement qui serait à l'origine des
nombreuses difficultés en raison du
manque de conducteur depuis le 1er
janvier on a vu une très forte
dégradation du service on demande à ce
que IDFM prenne toute disposition pour
garantir la continuité de service public
auprès de l'opérateur transdef
interpellé par les élus du territoire
Valérie PCR président d'î de France
mobilité n'a pas tardé à réagir la
situation dans la vallée de Chevreuse
n'est pas acc able et nous suivons de
très près la situation des solutions
enfin été trouvées à court terme la
qualité de service la régularité la
ponctualité l'information voyageur sont
au cœur de nos préoccupations il est
primordial que les opérateurs puissent
tenir ses engagements pris dans le
contrat à l'issue d'une réunion avec les
élus Transdev s'est engagé à assurer 100
% des lignes scolaires dès la semaine du
15 janvier dans son communiqué
l'opérateur affirme qu'une vingtaine de
conducteurs supplémentaires devraient
être recrutés et affecté le plus
rapidement possible sur le réseau si les
engagements ne sont pas tenus Île de
France mobilité demandera la mise en
place d'une sous-traitance pour assurer
le
service